hey how's it going bros my name is ben
oh my god what what is it you are so
crunchy
I am so disgusted to be associated with
you listen I challenge you to a crunch
off with a try not to cringe challenge
oh I set your challenge nothing makes me
cringe more than me so I gladly accept
your challenge you folks at home can
play along with this try not to cringe
Challenge game that we came up with you
know I haven't even watched this video
and i already absolutely [ __ ] loathe
it but let's watch how bad can it be
well right off the bat that [ __ ] font
it's like the standard [ __ ] font in
Premiere if you see anyone with that fun
just [ __ ] them
the goal is tonight range to remember
kids pineapple apple Penn pineapple Papa
Pan Huson this [ __ ] guy got 9 million
use of this trend Apple oh now the real
train
[Music]
and pineapple apple pear this kind of
[ __ ] makes me want to die oh no
celebrity is doing stuff on stage oh no
[Music]
you had one job button you had one
[ __ ] job button
why can't you see Justin Timberlake is
he pain keep trying to press the button
Justin Timberlake Justin Timberlake
did you try pressing the button he
didn't press the but keep trying to
press the button Anna Kendrick try and
laugh it up oh my god no okay
here's the tip cringe cringe to school
with Peter pie okay number one if you're
ever on a live gaming event now under no
circumstances whatsoever do not try and
shake the guy's hand I already know what
we all know what's gonna happen I will
see you back okay one month it's gonna
be awesome to see
[Music]
oh oh oh that's the same face I did at
Conan that's the I'm dead inside face
[ __ ] this shit's gonna be a lot on the
internet forever this is gonna be a
cringe couplet
Oh God not another one I can't Felix why
do you do this to me
you know it's my ultimate weakness thank
you very much for your time and we're
gonna sit back to the desk right now
[Music]
so you have a normal guy ultimate no
cringe whatsoever and then you have this
dark creature of the night she's
committing a god-like commitment
oh if you're failing you gotta commit
and old boy this she commits that takes
balls that takes real [ __ ] balls
he'll get her face she's like yep yeah I
[ __ ] up but I'm gonna commit to it and
it's so funny because they're watching
American Beauty today oh oh oh
cringe school would Peter pie lesson
number five hundred if you're gonna talk
to someone about something related to
them and you never met before you better
damn make sure you know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about
especially a celebrity what's the one
with the rose petals that's not you no
really no really I swear to God
why do you keep like what do you think
is [ __ ] lying you [ __ ] dumb white
[ __ ] Jesus Christ
dibs what is your deck name uh it flies
you dies so so far I'm only halfway
there it depends on who you
so for this one Sims is gonna get the
choice with wax all right snipey it
depends on who the you was referring to
at least acknowledge that it was a [ __ ]
joke just be like you know what that was
pretty [ __ ] just do that just give him
that don't murder him like that
don't murder him with a dead look nice
outfit
doing have you seen chef oh you did hit
him he didn't mean he doesn't know what
chef face oh my god
what a [ __ ] idiot
he hasn't seen she doesn't even know
what it is
chef let me tell you chef it's a great
movie about a man they used to be a
five-star restaurant chef but then he
loses his business so he decides to
start a food truck and it's amazing it's
such a great film that really inspires
me I felt so inspired after I saw chef
got a great soundtrack great character
development and great story Thank You
idubbbz
for asking the right questions I Jack
septic I as always you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
I just think I'm sorry
why would you why would you do it why
would you I'd simply stop don't clap
don't clap no clapping on airplanes
should be forbidden I know this one part
that's like all main that's she's got
balls to do that in public which I can
respect cuz a lot of people couldn't
pull this [ __ ] up but the problem is
that it's just not funny these people
can't go anywhere they have to stand
with this girl
being a [ __ ] annoying okay last video
okay
great another [ __ ] handshake Jesus
Christ not the hand shell not the hand
[ __ ] literally that was as painful as
seeing all their dicks touch Jesus stop
stop with the handshakes
no more handshakes this is ban
handshakes how about we just do this hey
[Music]